Jeff, what are the common things, most common things that you're seeing and let's, let's yeah,
what are the most common things you're seeing of why people are getting suspended? Let's start there.
Great. Well, so there are the, one of the common things that I'm seeing is,
there are several of them, but one of them is, is people are setting up
their MCC account and they're, and a lot of them are doing it like on their first time,
fresh Google ads, like first ad they've ever ran. And it seems like there's a lot of guys
that are missing a step. And I know not, I don't know if everybody has access to the 2.0,
but I've been referring, if you have access to 1.0, that's how you should be setting up your ad.
If you have access to 2.0, your video goes over that in really good detail, but I've kind of
referred them all back to say, go back through that and just really, really slow. And a lot of
what it is, I'll use the word like the hierarchy of how you set up an MCC account. So what some of
them are doing is they're setting up, and this is going to be one type of suspension that I'm seeing.
So some people that are setting up their ads, they feel like they're getting some running and
then they have to get that verification comes through. Then they go run their verification
and they can't get verified. And what's, what I'm seeing as a common theme with them is they set up
the MCC. So they set up their, I'm going to call it like their Google ad profile. Like they use
that Gmail to open up a Google ads and they do an MCC. And then they start running campaigns
directly underneath that. And if you go into the MCC, there's actually a spot where it says add
account. And you need to, before you run a campaign, you need to add an account that goes
underneath that, that goes inside of that or under, if this was like your Google ad profile,
you add an account here and then you add a campaign underneath that. And that's how like
the hierarchy of it should go. What's happening is people are setting up that, yeah, you got a
piece of paper. Yeah. Just what you're saying. It's like, yeah, by the way, real quick, for those
that are just brand new today, tell them what an MCC account, I know we're going very fundamental,
but let's just, what is an MCC account for someone that's like, what's that mean?
Well, it's, I would prefer people not do it until they have like 15 or 20 ads because it
gets confusing if you've never done it. But essentially it's, it's an account that you use
to manage quote unquote other people's ad accounts or you get brought on as a verifier. So like I run
a lot of Google ads for some political consulting that I do, and I will get added as the admin
or the manager for them. So my, my account will take over and has access to it. Basically it's
through a proxy that they give me. When you set up your own MCC and you set up the own accounts,
you can do that. But it, if you've never done one, it can be a little confusing for people.
Some people are setting up their MCC as a, like just like, it's like a solo account instead of
just doing an account. And on the right-hand side where your little profile picture is,
it's just adding an account, adding an account, add an account. They're kind of running the MCC
that same way. And that's not how that's supposed to be managed. So the MCC is kind of like the,
like the overseer of multiple ad accounts. Like I have multiple ad accounts for multiple clients
that are not related to each other at all. So guys, essentially if you guys like,
let's say it's your first time you go to Google ads. And I, and to my understanding, Jeff, maybe
you can correct me if I'm wrong, but I don't think they ever just automatically give you an
MCC account. It's by default, they just give you a regular account, right? Yeah. You have to, yeah,
you do have to, I think I'm going to use the word apply for it. It's been so long since I've done
that, but I think you just hit it and you like kind of apply for it when you sign up initially
and you can apply for it. But that, that's kind of what's triggering some of these people's
verification issues. And because they didn't set up the MCC right, the way that it's the, they,
they don't have like the account and then the campaign, they have all the campaigns under it.
Well, that, that's supposed to be you like directly who you are. And you try to verify like
all of a sudden five or six websites. And it's like, Whoa, so the Google AI bot that's checking
it just goes, that looks weird. That's not, that's not who you say you are. Cause you all of a sudden
have five or six different like websites or properties you're advertising on. If it was
my property that I registered and I'm running direct ads for me, like say it for my business
and more my domain and everything would match. They might go, Oh, that makes sense. I get it.
You're running your own ads there. But when I'm running like concrete experts and you know,
outdoor kitchen or whatever, I have to set those up in a certain way so that it shows that my main
account is managing that accounts campaigns. Correct. That makes sense. So if you, if you go
in, you've never done ads and you go in, it's, you're going to just set them up. Like he's
talking about, because you're not going to have an MCC account, which is basically a manager account.
Once you, once you convert or apply for an MCC, all he's saying is guys, just make sure that with
each separate property, you guys create an account first as an additional layer. And then
you create the campaign inside of the account. And I saw Marie Marie just said like an umbrella.
It's exactly like that. It's kind of like this. Let's call the top layer is like a grandpa,
right? And then the accounts are your parent accounts. And then you have the child account,
which is the campaigns. So just make sure we're not skipping a step. And guys, with any of these
suspensions, here's how I look at it. You can get mad at Google all you want, but if I was Google,
I would do the same exact shit they're doing. Can you imagine somebody this randomly gets on
and they put in a credit card and let's say it's a word to get into this, it's a gift card or some
random card and they never spent any money. They have a brand new account. I don't know who you are.
I don't give a shit about your 20 bucks a day. I'm Google. I would much rather suspend you.
And then my thinking would be, well, if he's serious about this, he's going to hit me up.
He's going to reach out. He's going to appeal. And if he appeals, then we'll deal with it.
That's a way better because if not, if they just let everyone spend money,
now I'm complaining. We're dealing with the bank. We've got all these partners. So guys,
you get mad at Google all you want, but at that level, you would do the same exact thing.
So whenever you're doing something, think about it. Is this going to look sketchy?
Is this going to make Google think that I am somebody that's sketchy? Guys, a gift card that
has a finite amount of money on the damn card. Like if you were my client, I wouldn't let you
take, put a gift card in there. So why would Google? So that's number one, make sure that it's
set up properly. And I like the word Jeff used hierarchy. You got the MCC, then you got the
account, then you got the campaign. If you don't have an MCC, it's just going to be your regular
login. And then you're going to go straight into your, I think it's just straight into campaigns.
You can only have one, it's one account, right? Well, so you have like your, it's kind of weird
because Google doesn't do a good job of defining it, but like under your ad profile, let's say
whatever Gmail you use, then you set up a Google ad account. If you go back and hit that icon in
the top right, you can just add another account. You just hit add Google account and it kind of
sets it up very similarly to an MCC. Well, you have to log in and out of these different emails.
No, I mean, you can't set up that way. I have, I have multiple, I have like five emails that they
use. And I have the same, I have the same credit card on them. I have the same PayPal account on
them. Like, yeah. So you're almost creating an MCC account by without having an MCC account,
because you have these, you're separating them by different emails or whatever. Some, yes. I have
like kind of groups. And if you go back to like, if for the ones that, if the 2.0 training setting
up the MCC is confusing, if you go back to the 1.0, the original, I think it's module three,
you'll see how you set up a campaign there. You can follow that method and you'll, and that,
like that will be easier if you've never done it. And it's probably going to give less flags and
it's less opportunity for you to screw up. Like what is an ad? What is an account? What is a
profile? What is a campaign? And so I think that anyway, so that's something I would tell everyone,
just go back to those trainings if you have access to one or the other and just go slow.
And by the way, my thought process there, the reason why I used this new account is because
in version 1.0, we did it that way. So I wanted, cause other people were like, well, what about
when it's this way? So that, if you need to just access both, you get the training, you get this
1.0, 2.0 up till whatever point out. So that's number one. What's what else? What other other
things you're seeing? And that's it. So that, are you seeing that trigger a circumventing or a
suspicious payments? I think that one is mostly triggering verification suspension. So they're not
letting people verify. I believe there's been one or two policy violations that had set up their
campaigns wrong in that way. And that's triggering a, a, an issue.